let's pull this story let's talk about
the good doctor Jordan Peterson The
Daily Mail says controversial Jordan
Peterson tears up as he agrees he's a
hero to incel men and responds to Olivia
Wilde calling him an insane pseudoel
intellectual saying it really didn't
bother me this is a great story it's an
important story uh Jordan Peterson makes
a really good point when he says uh oh
so he's asked by Piers Morgan you know
are you a hero to incel man he says okay
why not and then he actually starts
crying which you know I he cries a lot
he's a very empathic person and I think
that he he knows he's a hero to Intel
men because he's like these men have no
one else saying this to them strike a
chord with him this is what he says he
says something's the effect of you know
it's interesting how there are men who
don't know what to do they're lonely and
unsuccessful and they're and they're
trying to figure out how to improve and
they're just attacked and insulted and
you you get these you know insults
against them he says I thought the
marginalized were supposed to have a
voice instead you people like Olivia
Wilde saying she made a movie based on
him in in what way is Jordan Peterson in
any way insane you know it's just like
they just hate anyone who I I suppose
it's you know I got a business I really
don't understand why they hate Jordan
Peterson so much but I have to assume
that it's because he's empowering them
to the individual yes I think so I was
actually thinking about this earlier
today because I was listening to a remix
of his spoken word as I sometimes do
because what he has to say is
interesting and wise and I was thinking
I think that they hate him because
they're evil and he's trying to
construct people and they only know how
to destroy people and they're doing that
with him just like they've done with
lonely men over the past few years that
was what I came up with I I'm I'm
gravitating toward the idea that they
truly are evil because it seems I think
it's their source of their identity
comes from this you know culture war
that they perceive Jordan Peterson to be
the enemy and because maybe I don't know
they didn't have a loving family or
something like that that they have to
cling to the tribe of uh me too you know
and that it they'll just continue with
that regardless of how much it's
grounded well just to add to this point
I think they also prop themselves up by
stepping on other people I think that's
the norm and this is why Jordan Peterson
is is such a horrible person to them
because he's like hey don't get stepped
on hey hey stand up for yourself you're
a human being have some dignity have
some respect for yourself and it
counters the agenda which is going along
with the destruction of the modern man
have a dirty room have a dirty room
don't be organized don't have your stuff
together because that's bad for business
because when you're disorganized when
you're disheveled when you don't have
family when you're mentally and
physically weak you're you're the
perfect consumer and I think that's
exactly what they're after they want you
to be a consumer it's bad for business
when people stand up for themselves when
they have families when they're healthy
when they're happy and this is why
Jordan Peterson trying to help people is
not along with the agenda we have to
stop Jordan Peterson because Jordan
Peterson is stopping our agenda is it is
it is this is there truth to this claim
when like you see women like Olivia
Wilde saying the stuff that they have
bad relationship with their fathers yes
100 because maybe it's because of how I
was raised but I had a really good
really solid relationship with my dad
and I still consider myself really lucky
for that but I see that a lot of people
I think I there's nothing else you can
conclude I think that's what they're
missing what do you think Richie well I
think I I have a personal connection
with Jordan Peterson because when my dad
was sick I started listening to his Old
Testament lectures yeah and that was
really right when he was coming into the
public sphere and I think that's part of
it too is there's a religious component
there which is one of the reasons why
Jordan Peterson is is threatening
because he's articulating all of these
kind of old biblical ideas in a modern
context and it resonates with people and
it's people see a Resurgence of the
religious right which you know growing
up I didn't I didn't understand the
power of it until I was confronted with
something as difficult as you know like
a tragedy in your family but I think
that that's really what it is is Jordan
Peterson actually has a point and that's
that's scary to people who like things
the way they are where they have power
they want in cells they want white
supremacists so when Jordan Peterson
comes out and says identarianism is bad
and don't be an Intel improve your life
they're like oh he's damaging our access
to a boogeyman you know the immediate
desperately desperately tries to come
out claiming everyone's a white
supremacist or a white nationalist Vox
has that famous article where it's like
what was it like 11 million people have
white supremacist views or some other
ridiculous nonsense and then John
Peterson comes out and he's like hey
don't have these views don't be a
collectivist pick up the heaviest thing
you can find and carry it work on
yourself clean your room all of these
things are going to turn these in cells
into functioning members of society it's
going to give them strength and these
woke people are terrified of it
it's one of the main things standing in
there uh in their way of full Conquest
the full control of of humanity is the
subjugation of the Modern Men and I do
believe they were successful especially
when you look at testosterone levels
sperm levels mental health physical
health it's all declining along with IQ
so so there is something else going on
here and seeing this kind of concerted
attack against individuals who are there
to predominantly help people should be
concerning for the average viewer should
be concerning for anyone watching this
because we are seeing the destruction of
the modern man I don't think that's a
crazy statement to assert here uh
because the results are clear especially
in our current political and societal
system uh you can't ignore it so I think
we do need help but but no one's helping
them and the only person who is is
getting uh is getting attacked how does
that make sense by the way I I actually
just looked it up to make sure
from what I recalled but I did a
freelance gig in DC with a guy named uh
Andrew cockburn and there was a photo of
Olivia Wilde and I looked it up to let's
see that's her name yeah so that I met
Olivia Wilde's dad and answered Olivia's
question and he's a journalist and I I
don't I don't really I didn't glean much
from the interview itself because I was
just you know setting up cameras and it
was an interview but he seemed to be a
nice guy
um well but I don't know if you know she
could just be pandering right Olivia
Wilde is like hey yeah exactly exactly
but people often say like when you see
these feminists these women on Twitter
it's like they had a bad relationship
with their father I'm wondering is that
just a meme or is that come from
somewhere is that true that women with
bad relationships tend to lash out in
this way well so as far as I can tell
it's not feminists typically that are
accused of having daddy issues it's
women who are on places like only fans
who are seeking the approval of men
actively over the top being hoes
honestly I think it's just we have a
culture like you said of the story
Rachel dolezal hasn't only fans oh gosh
I saw that oh well there's also there's
also a lot of concerning stats when it
comes to single parent households and
households where the father is not there
especially when it comes to criminality
especially when it comes to people's
overall life expectancy their happiness
their health a lot of it is correlated
with how they're brought up and if
they're not brought up with a strong
family unit the individual does suffer
the child does suffer not just mentally
but also physically so I think those
stats can't be ignored Jordan Peterson
talks about them a lot and talks about
the importance of a family unit and I
think this is also again one of the
reasons why they're like hey he's bad
yeah he basically sticks his thumb in
the entire post-modern world order which
is like this this idea that everybody
had of you know we don't need all that
stuff you don't need to have this
nuclear family and a white picket fence
in a car in order to be happy and he
says no I mean that's what you're saying
it's like there's an agenda that's been
around for 40 years and he's just
calling it all out very effectively I
feel like someone's feelings or
expressed feelings about someone like
Jordan Peterson is a good indicator of
whether or not they're a sentient being
or an NPC I'm being somewhat facetious
but what I mean is
a rational person will say either I'm
not familiar I I've heard about Jordan
Peterson but I've not listened to him
before so I have no real strong opinions
or they'll say something rational like
you know I've listened to him I'm not a
big fan of some of the points he made
about religion I don't agree with or
they'll say I'm a big fan of the things
he said because
you know they said otherwise any one of
those responses indicates a thinking
person who's like you know let me try
and figure this out but the people who
are like he's an incel hero evil
alt-right whatever they clearly haven't
done any groundwork to understanding or
listening to anything that he has to say
so if you're trying to figure out if
someone is a Discerning individual or
let's just say an NPC in the in the
colloquial sense you can ask them about
Jordan Peterson Trump's too overt you
know everybody knows Trump he's up there
he's big there's always something to say
about him but these people I bet if you
went to Olivia Wilde and said really so
what don't what don't you like about
Jordan Peterson what do you think makes
him insane she would have no answer at
all she doesn't know because he's he's
famous enough but he's still obscure
enough where
with like my point is Trump's in the
news you can easily have remembered
something he said and then been like I
don't like how he handled this thing and
then you're like okay with Jordan
Peterson they're gonna have no nothing
because they don't actually listen to
anything he's ever said
yeah they're terrified of being canceled
you know that's everybody's that's the
culture that we live in today which is
everything that happens is Forever on
the internet and if you say one wrong
thing then your whole life is going to
be over and nobody wants to say that one
wrong thing because
I don't know that's that's the world we
live in where critical thinking isn't
valued over you're not supposed to think
you're supposed to react you're supposed
to have emotions you're supposed to of
course just go along with the group
think go along with the herb herd do
what you're told and and essentially
people thinking for themselves that's
extremely dangerous for a system that
thrives off of ignorance and there's a
lot of ignorance I think there's no
denying that I mean just she just
reminds me of like when you go to a
college and you interview the students
outside and say why are you protesting
Michael Knowles oh because he's a Nazi
well what did he say what was the what
was the thing he said well I heard you
know well I I know like she didn't
really write this script or anything
she I I do believe that you know I think
you guys are right that she says
pandering and I mean the stories the
story's about like a cult leader you
know in in like a town it's not like
that
it doesn't really have anything to do
with
Jordan Peterson is not a cult leader by
any means you know he's just like a an
intellectual a self-help he's trying to
help people do you have a Ukrainian flag
in your bio because if you don't I'm
coming for you thanks for checking out
this segment from the timcast IRL
podcast but if you want to check out the
full show live tune in Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and if you want more
special access content head over to
timcast.com and become a member your
membership helps sustain this company
keep our journalists employed makes this
show happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there